good morning everyone
i've actually brought you here on false
pretenses because
you've all come to chicago to attend a
functional programming conference you've
bought your ticket you've come along
and you want to see someone talk about
functional programming but actually this
talk isn't about functional programming
at all
it's about music although i will use a
functional programming language
to illustrate the examples i think
that's okay because
as a community we're at a critical
juncture where we need to convince the
rest of the software world
that we're not just ponderers we're
we're makers we're creators
that the beautiful functional languages
that uh that we admire so much aren't
self-complete artworks in themselves but
they're
the paintbrush they're the easel they're
the musical instrument that we're going
to use to build
other things and we're going to need to
do that to convince other people to
adopt
the tools that we know are so special
so i said it was going to be about music
so here's
a piece of music or rather it's a piece
of music notation
so this is western music notation it's
what people from the european orchestral
tradition would use to
represent music in visual form and if
you haven't seen it before
although i guess many people probably
have but it reads like a graph so on the
horizontal axis
is time so the further to the right the
later the note occurs
and on the vertical axis is pitch so the
higher up the note
the the higher the sound as well now i'm
going to claim that western music
notation
is a regular language in the sense of
regular expression or regular syntax
and there's a good reason for this which
is that western music notation is a
domain specific language
designed to be executed on a peculiar
kind of finite state machine called a
musician
so there is no stack if you're there on
stage you're performing away you don't
have the mental bandwidth to unravel
layers of nested abstraction that
someone composer is
is a painstakingly constructed you need
to know the literal output you need to
know what note you're playing next
and the limitation of this is that we
cannot build new concepts in western
music notation
sure there are there are random marks
and you might see some kind of
interesting
uh punctuation there but there's no way
to build that in the language itself if
you want a new concept and you have to
then you have to go around and update
all the clients you have to go and tell
every
musician who's likely to read your music
what this new mark means
so it's not extensible but that's a
feature given its use case of
being executed by people but we don't
have to
execute things by people we're
programmers we can execute things via
code and machines are very good at
unraveling layers of nested abstraction
so that we can build up our own
particular concepts that are unique even
to a piece or a genre
so technologically what i'm going to do
is i'm going to execute closure code
on a repel running in the background and
i'm going to use the overtone audio
environment to do this
which is written by sam aaron and jeff
rose
so let's start by defining what we mean
by sound
so basically sound is can you read that
it would be better and darker
apologies and it seems like the room is
more on the side of light
uh so to speak um all right so
um so it turns out that sound is really
a pressure wave
a sine wave that uh that oscillates
between high and low pressure
at a certain speed and the rate at which
it oscillates determines the pitch of
the sound
so here i've used an overtone macro to
just define a really simple
synth that just oscillates a sine wave
so let's hear that now
so it's kind of boring and plain yeah um
but we don't want to play a tone forever
or have to manually kill it if we're
going to play a note we want it to have
finite extent
so i'm going to use an envelope to make
the sound only last for a little bit of
time
so it fades out itself interesting
distortion from the speakers there as
well but that's
unintentional though it sounds quite
good all right so we've been able to
define a really basic sound but it's
quite it sounds quite thin and
artificial and to explain why that is
i need to talk to you about harmonics
and i'll step away from the code
slightly so
if we imagine that this is a string of
an instrument like a guitar
i pluck it and it vibrates and it's not
too hard to see that you might get a
pressure wave caused by the string
oscillating back and forth like this the
rate at which it oscillates
is dependent on the tension of the
string and this and the length of it
which is how you control it as a
musician you don't have to worry about
how loud uh how hard you pluck it
um and the reason that this uh has a
fixed
uh wavelength and frequency is that it's
actually forming a standing wave
crossing the x-axis
at both my hands um but you might also
wonder
why why that speed why not a sine wave
that's
half the size wouldn't that also form a
standing wave
and the answer is that yes it does so in
a real physically straight physical
string you don't have a single frequency
emitted when you pluck it
you have a series of frequencies so you
have the fundamental frequency
and then another sound that's twice the
frequency of that another one that's
three times the fundamental etc
and an infinite progression that
gradually fades out as the sound gets
higher
so i'm going to do a more complicated
synth now which is a bell
and i'm going to have the
fundamental frequency double triple four
five and six times and i'm going to sum
them up
and adjust them based on the proportions
that i control by the inputs here so you
can see it fading out the fundamental is
at one
and then point six point four etc so the
higher harmonics are softer and shorter
so let's play a bell sound
[Music]
alright so let's play the beep again
and the bell so the bells are much more
realistic sound but we can actually do
better than that so physically
bells have the effect of making their
higher harmonics
even higher than our naive model would
suggest
so the fourth or the third harmonic is
actually 4.2
times the bass frequency in my model
here so i'm going to just execute this
form again
and now i'm going to play the bell again
that sounds much more like a real belt
it's interesting that we recognize it as
a bell so you can clearly tell that
when we hear sounds there's something
going on not just in the air but there's
something going on between our ears
we have our own preconceptions and
models internally so i'm going to show a
really good example
of psychoacoustics just so that you to
hammer the point home that
sound and music is very dependent on the
receiver not just the emitter
so i'm going to play three notes one at
600 hertz then one at 500hz then one at
400hz so
high medium low
so high medium low
[Music]
oops
now the interesting thing about this is
i've actually overridden the proportions
of various harmonics and these three
bells
so the original sound there's a 600
hertz sine wave there that's the loudest
the longest the most dominant
but for the 500 hertz sound i've
actually given the
fundamental frequency a proportion of
zero so it's not there at all
and in the 400 hertz sound i've actually
suppressed the first harmonic as well
so the lowest and loudest sound in the
500 hertz note
is actually a thousand hertz well above
the 600 hertz
and for the 400 hertz sound the lowest
physical sound
is 1200 hertz 1200 oscillations per
second
so why do we hear it at high medium low
when the actual
sine waves would dictate we should hear
it in the other order
[Music]
the answer is that the harmonic
progression is something that is a
characteristic of almost all physical
sources of sound
so it's something that our brains have a
model of it's something that we
understand
if our brains come across a bunch of
frequencies that have
200hz 300hz 400hz 500hz
they know that there should have been a
100 hertz sound there as well
so it's able to error correct and put
that back in and that's not
an accidental well it's not an
unimportant detail for example
some speakers like for mobile phones
can't actually emit a sound low enough
to capture
the fundamental frequency of the human
male voice
yet we can recognize men speaking on the
phone because of this error correction
capability
so from what i've showed you so far uh
we've talked about a
basically a continuous pitch space i've
offered no guidance as to
all the different frequencies you could
play what would you choose as a musician
so i'm going to speak about that now so
this instrument is a digital instrument
because it doesn't have a dial it's not
continuous it's discrete
so literally speaking it's digital it's
not electronic but it is digital
um and what what what how do i choose
what button does what
well it turns out that for a um
for most western uh or even worldwide
musical traditions
doubling the frequency of a sound is
seen as changing it from one sound to
another equivalent sound you know this
tuesday to next tuesday
we know it's different but it's somehow
tapping into
an underlying sameness so i'll play two
notes that are
double the frequency of each other
so it's like the first two notes of
somewhere over the rainbow
um and between this there's actually 12
buttons
well or between there's 11. so there's
12
intervals to that octave to get between
one note and the next equivalent note
so because we're talking about a ratio
to go up an octave
each individual button represents
an increase of frequency by the 12th
root of two
ratio so i'll play a few
so each time i'm going up a button i'm
increasing the frequency
by the twelfth root of two it's
interesting that
we can recognize it so clearly when it's
actually quite mathematically a subtle
effect
so we can number the notes on a piano or
a melodica
or on any instrument and that system is
called midi
so we can start to define functions that
manipulate and calculate based on these
principles
so i've defined a function here midi to
hertz which takes
a numbering of the key and produces the
actual frequency
and the calculation is trivial just
based on multiplication and
explanation and so we can
execute media hertz of the midi note 69
and if you can see down the bottom there
i'll just
bring it up higher it's uh 440
well except for floating point error but
i would challenge any
any human being to tell the difference
between that and 440 orally
and that's called concert a so that's a
standard that is coming to use now it
wasn't always a standard
that orchestras will tune their
instruments too
uh and of course if i you know if i
increase and calculate i get
466.1 which is an increase of the
twelfth root of two
so i can start to plug my abstractions
together so i can use both the bell i
created and midi to hertz to create an
instrument
that is capable of playing not raw
frequencies but midi
and that gets me a little bit closer to
the domain because i don't want to worry
about all the infinite number of
frequencies that i'm not actually kind
of
allowed in some sense to play
so now that we have this model we can
start to actually model what a note is
so a note using a simple closure data
structures
i'm just defining as a time pitch pair
so it has a time it happens at it has a
pitch that it happens at
so quite analogous to the western music
notation we saw before
but i'm using kind of what looks like
jason possibly to non-closurists going
to use a couple of other
kind of helper functions here so where
is just a version of map that applies to
a particular key
so when i want to define a play function
on a sequence of notes
what i need to do is i need to take the
notes i need to translate
the time key from now or offset it so
that i play my piece not
at the start of the unix epoch in 1970
but as i actually want to now
and then i need to destructure to get
the milliseconds and the midi from each
note
and use the overtone at to ding at the
appropriate time
so just a fairly simple non-lazy map
operation
and so here is here i'm going to play
the midi notes from
70 through 80. and i've just used a
helper function
even melody which puts a third of a
second between each note
[Music]
all right so we're starting to climb
higher in the tower of abstraction
but there's something a little bit
unmusical about that
[Music]
so it's a sort of sound you might hear
in a movie for effect but it's not
actually something you'd expect to hear
in a song
and i'll explain why that's so i haven't
talked yet about scale
so we have all these notes here but in a
given piece we actually don't play every
single one
we choose a subset of it for the effect
of the piece
and the way that we choose the subset is
based on the distance between each note
so in a major scale
there is a double jump between the first
and the second
so we skip one note and then we skip
another note
then a single jump double double double
single
and and so on other scales have
different patterns of big and small
jumps
but we can quite easily represent this
as a as a as a function
by just giving the intervals and so what
major is now is it's a function
that takes a position in the scale and
gives me back the actual midi
now that gives us still a relative
measure because if i'm at the root node
in the scale how do i know what what my
starting point was
so we can use another function that is
just a simple integer offset
to represent uh where our reference
point is
so c is just a function that adds 60 to
whatever it's given
so that goes c of 0
it gives me 60. so if i functionally
compose together
c and major or c sharp major it's a
function which represents the key of c
major
and let me just um play a c major scale
or a c sharp major scale
right so that's much much more musical
because we're obeying the convention
that we only stick to the subset we're
allowed to play in the piece
now mage is only one way of constructing
a scale there's other ones like minor
blues which are governed by different
patterns of
large and small jumps so let's try
giving the audience let's try
an f sharp scale let's try f sharp blues
[Music]
right so there's a definite effect
you're hearing there right which is
which isn't just the mathematics it's
also
based on your cultural associations with
uh of those uh those that pattern of
big and small jumps so let's try um
something which is almost identical the
pentatonic scale
so the pentatonic scale is just the
blues scale with one mode missing
[Music]
very different effect though because
that's a scale that's commonly used in
east asian music so that's what you
associate it with
all right so now we're ready to start
putting together longer and more full
pieces
so i hope you can read that but this is
uh row row row your boat
i can try it in dark so both people get
to have a look
uh probably not
same colors are problematic yeah
um like
how's that all about
all right well maybe i'll just have to
find some way of representing it
non-visually for you
which i can guarantee is about to happen
all right so what i'm doing is i'm just
having an array or a list of a vector
enclosure of pitches and a vector
of durations and i'm using some standard
uh functional foo
reductions etc to put them together so
this is what a
roro row your boat looks like
again you probably can't see it so let's
go and find out
if we can play it so we take royabo we
transform
each of the times by 90 beats per minute
which is just another function it's just
a function that tells us based on a beat
how far into the piece we are and we
also transform the pitch
by c major so we're going to play row
row your boat
at 90 beats per minute in c major
[Music]
right and incidentally um what you're
seeing there is the output of play which
is
uh the notes themselves
so i've promised you when i talked about
the drawbacks of western notation that
we'd be able to construct abstractions
that are specific to the piece and the
genre we're talking about
um so let's let's have a look at that so
in bach
there are many sections of his music
that have a whole bunch of adjacent
notes running together so i'll just
switch back to the western music
notation so this is a bark piece
you can see there's a whole bunch of
notes with adjacent pictures
and if that pattern continues throughout
bach i should be able to specify these
runs as i call them
in terms of the peaks and the valleys i
shouldn't have to specify every note
and i'm pretty sure that if i was
talking to bach he wouldn't and he was
uh
explaining a piece to me he wouldn't say
you know that bit where it goes c d e f
g
a b c he wouldn't enumerate each node he
would say
you know that bit where there's a run
from c to c so by building that
abstraction it's still being reduced
down to the same
time pitch pairs but it gives me the
ability to express
a concept that's much closer to the
domain
so i'll evaluate a a run first so you
can see the plain numbers
just down the bottom of the screen there
but i'll actually
play it because it's much more effective
if you if you hear it orally
so there's plenty of sections in bark
that at least superficially sound like
that so if i want to notate bark
i want to use concepts that are close to
that domain i don't want to have to be
stuck with the lowest common denominator
that uh
western music notation represents
so here is um again you probably won't
be able to see the detail that well but
here's
the melody to canoni of a quarter and
i've taken advantage of the fact that
has a whole bunch of runs in it
that it has repeated durations so
there's 14 quarter notes in a row for
example here
and that lets me specify indirectly take
advantage of the redundancy
but also come much closer to the domain
and incidentally because i'm just in a
general purpose programming language i
can have
local bindings with different parts of
the melody so as i
hear this piece there's like a call then
a response then a development
and i can just call that out and give it
names but that's not something that
natively happens in western music
notation
and then there's a bass part as well so
i won't play
this for you just yet because there's
another concept i need to explain before
i can play this effectively
we're going to talk about what a canon
is so
a canon is a kind of musical form that
was popular in bach's day
and a canon is defined as a series of
notes that are accompanied
by a functional transformation of
themselves so you can see this one line
of closure actually captures
exactly what a canon is we have the
notes and we concatenate them
with a functional transformation of the
notes so what kind of
functional transformations are available
to us well there's something called
a simple canon which just takes the
original notes
and offsets the time so it's just a
delay
you play the second melody a little bit
after the first melody
there's an interval canon which is the
same as
a simple cannon except it's translating
in the pitch space so the accompanying
melody
is either raised or lowered by a fixed
amount so where pitch
is from interval there's a mirror cannon
for obvious reasons which is where you
apply negation
to every um to every pitch so everywhere
in the original piece where it ascends
in the accompaniment it descends there's
a crab cannon which is the
the time analog of a mirror cannon where
the accompaniment goes backwards in time
and that's so cool because in bach's
time it was commonly and puzzlingly
believed that crabs walked backwards
but these are so these are all pure
functions
so we can compose them together and
that's what baroque composers did
long before the lambda calculus was
invented
so there's a table cannon
is a functional composition of a mirror
and a crab cannon
so it's rotated around both axes in the
graphical form
and the reason it's called a table
cannon is imagine that you are seeing
western music notation or any graph on a
table in front of you and you have a
friend who's on the opposite side of the
table
if you both play what you see the person
on the other side is seeing it rotated
around both axes
so hence the table can it
so it happens that row row your boat is
playable as a cannon a simple cannon
so if i take the original melody and
then i do the canonic transformation and
play it again with a four beat delay you
get a nice effect so let's hear it
[Music]
all right so you don't expect that to do
that with every piece but if it's a
specifically chosen melody you will be
able to do that and as a matter of fact
actually
row your boat is a round which is an
extreme form of cannon where you can
actually
repeat that delay process and have four
melodies going at once
so before we get to the canoe other
quarter i'm just going to slightly
enrich my definition of canon which is
effectively the same
but i'm setting the follower parts the
accompaniment
to all have a key to indicate that
they're the follower
and we're going to use that in just a
second
so cannonial quarter which is this piece
by johan sebastian bark is a cannon
and it's a composition of three kinds of
kind of atomic cannon
so cannonial quarter is a functional
composition of an interval cannon
a mirror cannon and a simple cannon so
the accompanying melody
is uh fl is a lowered then flipped and
then delayed
and so you might imagine that composing
a melody that actually makes sense when
you apply such a complicated
transformation
is a very difficult thing and you would
be right and this is why bach is
regarded as a genius
so i'll play you canonial quarter which
i can
you can see i very clearly represented
the structure of it because i've got the
i've brought out the canonic structure
which you couldn't do with western music
notation
and because we're dealing with simple
data structures and pure functions i'm
also going to graph it at the same time
so here's cannoni other quarter by johan
sebastian valve
[Music]
all right so you can see we
didn't actually lose anything when we
moved away from western music notation
or at least not
in this terms we still have the ability
to graphically show what we're doing
because we're dealing with data and
we're dealing with functions and
we know how to deal with that stuff so
interestingly enough you can look at the
original melody and the shape there have
a look at this little bit here the blue
bit
so you can you can visually see that
it's a the canonic transformation it's
it's lowered and flipped and delayed
we've also got the bass part that
is interleaved throughout here so bach
was definitely a genius to be able to
construct
such intricate compositions and i um
i've certainly simplified some things in
order to represent it here
but i find quite inspiring because you
know he took
a really austere formal discipline like
cannons
and he breathed life into it he used his
human creativity to take
very precise and formal tools and make
something beautiful and
as a functional programmer i find that
quite inspiring because when we have our
lambda calculus and our
first class functions and our types
we're trying to take what is kind of
in some level a really inhuman system a
really cold system
but we're trying to put it together in a
way that is really meaningful for human
beings
so i'm going to change something about
how i played canonial quarter
i'm going to change the key from major
to minor
and because the way i'm expressing it is
quite domain valued i can make a small
change
to the way i'm representing it and that
will be a meaningful domain change so
that's i guess the to me the basic tenet
of domain driven design that have a
small change in domain terms should be a
small change
in code terms so i'm going to play it
again and what that means is that the
pattern of big and small jumps in how i
render it to a key is slightly different
so out of the octave there's two uh
notes that will be
the 12th root of two lower than they
otherwise would be
but let's hear what effect it comes with
[Music]
so it's much more serious the way i like
to think of it that sounds much more
like the
the soundtrack to a police procedural
whereas the original sounds much more
like a costume driver
it's interesting how well we pick up on
that because there's not a whole lot of
difference physically if you were doing
just a physical analysis of that sound
and you didn't really have the same
models that we have
it would be difficult for you to even
pick up that there was any difference
between that piece
so we're definitely wired for sound we
have you know first-class appreciation
for music
all right so so far that's been a little
bit static but um
this is lambda jam not lambda here's one
i prepared earlier so
i'll try to do something a little bit
more interactive to finish up it
so this is slightly more complicated and
i'll be moving a little bit quicker but
maybe just
if you if you don't understand a
specific thing i'm doing just
uh just listen to the music and it will
guide you so i'm using a
a closure multi method to say that any
any note with the part
beat should be played with this sample
which is actually from a drum kit
and any other note so default should be
played on the sample piano
and so i'm starting with nothing here
just to show you that it's not actually
too hard to do and what i'm going to do
is i'm going to use the jam
function which is going to construct a
basically an infinite lazy sequence from
our
melody but it's only going to realize it
as it needs more
and it's going to call it by reference
so i can change the melody as i write it
and each time it goes around the loop
we'll get our updated changes
so we've got nothing here there's no
notes so let's define
the first start of a baseline
so it's a single note that lasts for
four beats
um and at the zero degree so
in this case i'm using b flat major so
that single note is a b flat so i'm
going to reevaluate this form
and now i'm going to well oops
let me just evaluate the whole file
first now i'm going to re-evaluate this
form
now that's going to kick it off and i'm
going to gradually introduce more
changes and hopefully explain what i'm
doing
but i hope that you'll you'll be able to
make sense of it from the music anyway
all right so there's a single note it's
repeating the lazy sequence is
unraveling as we need more of it
so let's make this a bit more
complicated and a bass line should
really be
a lambda because the bass line can
repeat
on different levels
so we're going to give it the zero chord
zero chord three chord
zero fourth zero we'll just
update the definition
um and then offset the note
by by the note we've passed in
and reevaluate as long as it compiles
then the next time it comes around it's
going to start playing through that
progression that i defined here
it's still a bit high though so it's
hitting the three note
back to the root
so i'm going to lower it which will only
take effect the next time through
but let's lower it twice because it's
the base part so it should be quite low
all right here we go all right
sounds better it's more like a bass part
all right so let's walk the bass through
the chords
[Music]
so i'm just hitting all the notes in the
chord
uh including the sixth to give it a bit
more of a jazzy feel
all right so define it again so next
time we go around we want to walk the
bass rather than just hitting really
uninteresting notes
that's more jazzy right so this is
actually a rendition of in the mood
which is a famous glenn miller tune
but i think we need a beat as well which
will be a
single note followed by two half notes
um
actually we need to cycle through that
so you want to do it forever
each time we need to take
12 notes and we want to repeat it
six times for each chord
all right so the hook the melody is a
bit more complicated so i may
stuff this up as i'm trying to do it so
the hook
it needs to be a function of two things
first of all is a
progression because it's repeating at
different uh
different places
and also the shape of what is repeating
changes
so it needs to be an inversion to start
off with
a triad
then we want two of those
we want a plane triad
we want one of those another one of
those
[Music]
all right so there's a different pattern
that's being repeated here
that's all right so far but now i'm
going to have to actually use those
triads to find
so hook is another lambda
[Music]
we take the chord we're passed in which
is the second argument
we take the values from we sort it we
cycle it
then we give it a timing which is
actually
repeating 11 times a half note
[Music]
and then we also need a longer note at
the end
all right and we need to translate that
based on the progression which is
the first one we passed in the first
argument
so that compiles which is a good sign so
hopefully the next time we go around
we'll actually hear the melody on top of
it and then it'll sound much more like
in the mood
so there's one big thing missing still
all right so back to the root chord
all right so now to the fifth which is
kind of the signal we're about to finish
and go back
and now we're back home so it's about to
repeat again and let's hope it
sounds right
all right hear the melody
but there is still something really
missing here which is that
there isn't any swing like literally
there's no swing it's just completely
straight
but that's no problem because swing is
quite easy to code actually
it's entirely analogous to
scale it's making the the first half of
the note
to be a big one and the second half to
be a small one so i can just use the
same scale function that i used before i
don't need any change
and i need to just because we're talking
about half notes uh
adjust it by a back of two
whoops
some added swinging that still compiles
i think probably it's about time that we
put a bit more juice into it as well so
that's like 130 beats
130 beats from that
all right so you can hear the swing that
swing there
just so of course in a real piece of
music they would
probably wouldn't do it so extremely but
it is actually something you can
represent
quite finely there's no problem so just
try something else
um so we've got our chords of arpeggios
right so the chords are not all being
played at once we're playing each bit
individually
so just want to try um
um just taking out
the bit that makes it into an arpeggio
that gets the values
and just repeat the chord itself just
for effect
all right on the fifth back to home
so let's put it back so when we get back
in
me
[Music]
all right so let's change the key
and razor
[Music]
especially
all right key change
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right so the way we get out of this
eternal catchy loop is to set our
bar back to kneel
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so now we're in the blues scale an
alternate pattern of big and small jumps
[Music]
thanks very much